well I have never done a children's book
I had early on shortly after I got out
of the army in 1953 I put some samples
together hoping to get some kills book
illustrator but I ran a cropper of
somebody named sendak I was starting out
and his work was so devastatingly
impressive that I thought I'd better get
out of the way and let him have that
field and help fight something on my own
so that in a way I gave up children's
books because of the Murrays and
dedicated myself as a cold war
cartoonist Ryan overthrow the government
so it was it was by default and and and
with the Tollbooth Norton justa who
wrote it was a first day a young man who
became a friend because we live in the
same building in Brooklyn Heights and
then we moved into a duplex apartment
together with a third roommate and
that's where he started writing the
Phantom Tollbooth and he would read to
me section and I'd start doing sketches
I was all by by accident by proximity
Norton was there I was there he loved
the school thing old nineteenth and
early twentieth century English line
drawing illustration so that's what I
try to give him in my version of it
because his his Oh his own were hotel
writing style was basically geared to
the early 20th century so it all again
it was one of those things that I backed
into and I and it was accidental and it
was great fun to do but once it was done
I had no intention of doing more
children's books this is in the 60s and
it was another 30 years or so before I
decided to write and illustrate my own
and I actually have just completed 50
years later my second book with Norton
justa called the odious ogre which will
be coming out in the fall of 2010 and
that's a big picture book in color and
very different style from from the
Phantom Tollbooth
well it's um I found it was my good
fortune somehow to be able to work in
these forms that I loved when I was a
kid I mean I love movies and I could
write screenplays I love theatre and I
could write plays I mean they would be
my own I could never write what would
used to be called a well-made play but
mean I could but my first play little
murders turned out to be a great success
and and and a great influence on on
plays of that time carnal knowledge
which was originally written as a play
still resonates and people still talk
about it and it Mike Nichols production
of the film is the best collaborative
work I've ever done with anybody and it
still holds up and people still talk
about it and and so I've had an enormous
lock an enormous pleasure in working in
these phones and just because I could
always write dialogue because I always
had a sense of how people spoke and
because i had a strong narrative sense
growing up loving stories loving novels
I just seemed to know how to tell a
story and be and I read a lot i went to
a lot of movies i went and went to a lot
of plays and I and it rubbed off on me
and that's all it just rubbed off on me
I mean if it would all they had not been
writing in the 50s just when I was
coming along getting interested in
theater never have written a play but
all they suddenly open the doors because
he was doing stuff in a form that i
found terribly inviting and and God
knows I didn't would never have thought
of it on my own
you